[Music]
with her trademark Bob and dark
sunglasses Anna winter rules the 300
billion dollar American fashion Universe
Anna is the single most influential
individual in the world of fashion
as editor of Vogue magazine she's become
a celebrity herself
with a reputation as Fairy Godmother to
some Anna Winters approval is important
anything I do and fire-breathing dragon
to others I've heard names ice queen
nuclear winter I'm sure she's demanding
to get results you do have to be
demanded is she warm and fuzzy no why
should she have to be her influence has
moved beyond the pages of the glossy
magazine she's a Pacesetter and power
broker she is the woman that bought
fashion to Big Business and to the world
globally
[Music]
I I don't know anything about uh fashion
and I don't read Vogue regularly but I
know a lot about you Vogue editor Anna
winter confronted her storied reputation
head-on in a rare late night television
appearance I read in the New York Times
this week that I'm an ice queen I'm the
Sun King
I'm an alien fleeing from District 9 and
I'm a dominatrix
foreign
so I reckon that makes me a lukewarm
royalty with a whip from outer space
what do you think a good gig
[Music]
per gig is editor-in-chief of Vogue
magazine for 22 years the powerful and
intimidating queen bee has told women
what and who to wear
long skirts or short royal blue or Navy
or that gray is the New Black I adore
fashion I adore what it says about women
Vogue has a recognition that no other
magazine has and that it's deeply
satisfying to me and is revolutionary
she's the she revolutionized the whole
modern fashion industry
Anna is someone who responds to
competitiveness in a way that you wish
everyone did she doesn't get angry she
gets even
winter manages her media profile
carefully and declined to participate in
this program
[Music]
Anna winter was ambitious from a young
age born in London in 1949 she dropped
out of school it was the 60s and she was
captivated by London's cultural and
social scene
her mother Eleanor was American and her
British Father Charles was the
hard-nosed editor-in-chief of the London
newspaper the evening standard Laurie
Schechter began her career as Anna
Winter's assistant she grew up in a home
with a journalist a newsman there's a
certain standard and rigor of work there
that definitely got passed on to her and
is the way she approaches everything
that she does now when she was 20 winter
got her well-dressed foot in the door at
the newly formed British magazine
Harpers and queen
she was intensely competitive she angled
to work with the best photographers to
climb up the ladder but after five years
at Harpers and queen she was passed over
for the position of editor-in-chief
she left the magazine and England and in
1975 headed to New York's 7th Avenue
Vera Wang sits on top of her own fashion
Empire and has known winter for over 30
years she was not
Anna Winter High Priestess of Vogue
if she was my friend and we were two
girls that were looking
to get something going in the fashion
industry and Dana was definitely
set about going to the magazine business
and and particularly Vogue
but Vogue would have to wait Winter's
first job in New York was at Harper's
Bazaar she was fired for being as she
claimed in a newspaper interview two
European
after a few months without work she
accepted a job offer from Penthouse
Magazine publisher Bob guccione as
fashion editor at Viva an erotic
magazine for women
her fashion layouts one recognition
a few years later she landed her first
big job
fashion editor at New York Magazine she
was a complete mystery fascinating
mystery she wore the dark glasses pretty
much 100 of the time
it is sink or swim she tells you what
she wants and she's not going to tell
you how to do it I lost eight pounds in
two weeks and it's just because it was
constant
winter was building a reputation for
stylish layouts and a Relentless work
ethic
very set agenda
had the courage
and the guts and the intelligence and
the energy to do all of this
it wasn't long before the executives at
Conde Nast Sai new house and Alexander
Lieberman took notice Tom Florio was the
publishing director at Vogue and has
known winter for 30 years in those early
days of conding ass they almost felt
like a young Hollywood studio you know
and Mr Newhouse with Alex just had this
great sense of how to build not only
magazines but personalities to lead
these magazines the organization really
embraced people with vision and
determination and drive no one had more
of that drive than Anna winter she was
rewarded with a job at Vogue created
just for her it wasn't the job she was
aiming for that was already taken by
long-time editor-in-chief Grace
Mirabella there was obviously resistance
but when Anna comes in she's not a
Wallflower and she's gonna make her
point of view known and that's why she
was brought there
Winter's point of view was not welcomed
by Mirabella in her autobiography
Mirabella described the new creative
director s cold and suspicious always
working against her to undermine her
Authority she wrote that she felt winter
was being groomed for her job
I think there were those who felt
threatened
know her they didn't know quite why is
there
unnecessarily welcome anyone new
let alone someone like Anna who cut
quite a striking figure
caught your eye and definitely had the
attention of the major decision Maker's
economy nest
after a three-year power struggle Conde
Nast put an ocean between them they
offered winter a promotion to
editor-in-chief of British Vogue
moving up the corporate ladder brought
new excitement but it came at a tough
personal cost she moved to London with
her new baby while her husband stayed
behind in New York Anna winter arrived
in London in 1986 and immediately began
to alter the shape of British Vogue in
in some ways she brought it more Down to
Earth for those who wanted to maybe
actually find things that they could buy
and made it more serviceable for the
reader
the readers may have enjoyed the change
but her staff was not as accepting they
gave her a nickname that stuck nuclear
winter it's a little bit the Greta Garbo
thing if you don't say a lot and don't
sort of engage people but that you know
then leaves the rest of the world to
make up what they think is the truth is
she warm and fuzzy you know
no why should she have to be is she
someone you'd like her opinion
absolutely after 18 months Conde Nast
brought their up-and-coming star back to
New York to overhaul their shelter
magazine House and Garden
winter changed the title to HG out were
photos of empty rooms in where lavish
spreads of celebrities in their homes
readers revolted and the magazine was
forced to hand out subscription refunds
Terry agins is a former senior fashion
writer for the Wall Street Journal and
the author of the end of fashion I mean
that's why I call Anna revolutionary
because I mean even her plan to like
come in and do something that radical to
a uh an established magazine the
prospect for failure is high when you do
something that that gutsy these failures
would have ended many a career but not
Anna Winters Conde Nast still had other
plans for her it was the worst kept
secret in the Fashion World there have
been rumors that Miss Wintour would
become the editor of American Vogue
replacing the veteran Grace Mirabella
well now the hot publishing story is
that this probably will happen after 17
years Mirabella was out
38-year-old Anna winter got the job she
always wanted her vision was clear from
her first cover she paired a ten
thousand dollar top with 40 jeans that
signaled something new revolutionary
this was a new editor she was British
she was stylish she was young and you
know and she really had a point of view
we knew that this was going to be a new
era in a December 1988 interview winter
explained what it takes to be
editor-in-chief of Vogue that I think is
what's so important in this job is to
have the right kind of instinct and gut
reaction to produce a magazine that is
of the moment that just captures what's
going on
right now I mean that's what it is to be
in Vogue
mirabella's traditional headshots were
replaced with Winter's fresh new look
she spared no expense on elaborate photo
shoots with the best photographers I
[Music]
desire for escape
and for beauty and for real fashion with
our knee devs things that are relevant
to us as women
things that fit into our lifestyle and
who we are and where we've come
once again winter saw the Allure of
celebrities and replaced supermodels
with superstars on the cover filmmaker
RJ Cutler very early on Anna Wintour saw
that celebrity
power Global industry and fashion were
all coming together we had the mega
Brands Gucci Prada lvmh working women
became executive women
and so they needed power suits for work
she understood the glamor of high
fashion the desire to make people dream
to Aspire to inspire but she also
understood how fashion as a business had
changed
Winter's growing reputation captured
increased advertising dollars
ednardozza is the editor of women's wear
daily the advertising business can be
very fickle you have to build loyalty
over time you have to provide real value
and reasons for advertisers to
consistently stay in your Publications
because it is one of the most
competitive Industries in the world
in 10 years ad revenues climb from just
over 87 million dollars to nearly 150
million dollars
vogue's success brought winter increased
power
her front row appearances at fashion
shows wearing her trademark dark glasses
took on new meaning
every glacial expression was scanned for
Clues
and became someone very important
porscho
showed that the show was cool that means
that the show is like a big deal
Vogue under winter was on a journey from
magazine to bran
success brought winter increased public
scrutiny in 1999 the tabloids ran with
the story of her divorce and her
relationship with millionaire Texas
Communications executive Shelby Bryan
people gossip and and speculate about
her every move but she is just basically
risen above it and I think it's a smart
thing to do
undistracted winter was focusing her
attention on what was ahead for Vogue
her answer was invariably the same
people are always asking what was that
your favorite collection was that your
favorite issue and it to me it's always
the next one it's the it's the idea of
what is to come it's always the future
always the future most editors don't
think beyond their title but Anna thinks
about the world and how it impacts the
title that's how the title can impact
the world
Charles Townsend is the CEO of Conde
Nast Publications she's involved in all
aspects of the globe brand whether it's
marketing the brand to the consumer
whether it's marketing the brand to the
advertising Community you know it's
political influence it's social
influence she manages that Brand's
positioning across all of those
parameters
to extend the brand in 2003 she launched
team Vogue men's Vogue and Vogue living
followed
in one year add revenue from Men's Vogue
dropped over one million dollars
in 2008 Conde Nast cut it to an
occasional supplement
U.S Vogue living disappeared
only Teen Vogue survived on the
newsstands
the brand extension didn't quite work
but those were natural and productive
experiments she takes risks she works
really really hard and when life doesn't
work she's she brushes it off and she
recovers and just tries to learn from
the situation and move on
myself
[Applause]
[Music]
Winter's increased visibility and her
public support of the fur industry
attracted some wild confrontations
during the height of the anti-firm
movement you know Anna was defined she
was wearing her furs
the protesters would show up at the
shows
she was having lunch at the Four Seasons
and someone put a dead animal in her
plate if you're walking through Paris
and somebody hits you with a pie and
knocks you down that's pretty aggressive
anybody else would have been upset when
she stood up wiped her face she said
this is getting really boring went back
to the hotel changed and made her next
meeting
after that
that she comes into the show and she's
accompanied by these two bodyguards this
also helps stoke the myth that she's you
know in a class by herself
she dug in her stylish stilettos never
wavering in her support for the
multi-billion dollar fur industry the
more her reputation grew the more
unwelcome attention she got the novel
The Devil Wears Prada was considered by
many in the fashion industry to be a
thinly disguised and devastating
portrayal of winter
the Hollywood version starring Meryl
Streep was a huge hit grossing over 326
million dollars in theaters worldwide
give me that little table that I like at
that store
reservation for dinner tonight at that
place
this Dragon Lady reputation or is often
portrayed I think there's some kind of
gender issue here because she's a woman
people expect her to behave a certain
way and I think if she were a CEO
running a company there would be no
issue
[Music]
winter was now a recognized power broker
with wide reaching relationships
throughout the fashion industry she's
been very instrumental in many of the
very large Brands when they were looking
for a standard Bearer or a Creator or a
designer or a creative director she has
been instrumental in helping those
Brands succeed as well
[Music]
one brand that needed her help was gap
for years the company had been suffering
from declining sales they consulted
winter and she recommended young
designer Patrick Robinson so I think she
called me and that's just what my
thoughts were and sort of gave me some
thoughts about what the job sort of
could look like more from how she saw it
and just as a per it was more personal
so it was that simple but she was this
great sounding board for me when I was
thinking about the job her matchmaking
worked in 2007 Robinson became gap's new
Executive Vice President of design Anna
Winters approval is important anything I
do it still is she's the first steal to
this day that sees everything I do but
after four years of lackluster results
the Gap dismissed its star designer
Winter's interest in supporting new
Talent led her to create the Vogue
fashion fund to provide grants and
business advice you have to keep that
feeder system going Anna was really
interested in making certain we continue
to have more designers which means more
advertisers and more sales so all this
works together
everything came together in September
2007 when winter delivered the fall
season premiere issue of Vogue the
magazine had a record-breaking 727 pages
of advertising
anyone coming to this run through except
for me it became the subject of the hit
documentary The September issue a rare
look inside Vogue and the demanding
woman running it's gorgeous
[Music]
no
this type seems so large and pretentious
looks like it's for blind people
and it does not look back she looks
forward she does not doubt she trusts
herself she requires a thick skin but
you know even a thick skin has nerves
under it she would need steel nerves in
2009 we found ourselves facing economic
circumstances through the recession that
we never imagined were possible
in 2009 the deepest recession in decades
was forcing business to slash
advertising dollars
Vogues add sales for the all-important
September issue plunged from 727 pages
in 2007 to 429 in 2009.
Conde Nast is a private company that
does not publicly report Financial
results
clearly the company was under pressure
they shuttered six of their magazines
and cut hundreds of jobs but their Crown
Jewel Vogue managed its costs and
managed to escape drastic cuts
7th Avenue was also being squeezed by a
shopping slowdown winter took on a new
mission
New Yorkers you're always in fashion
always
a worldwide retail Extravaganza called
Fashions Night Out fashion industry is
counting on you
[Music]
that this was an unprecedented event
that brought together over a thousand
retailers around the world
and thousands and thousands of consumers
flooded the stores
[Music]
peaceful that it has become an annual
event
[Applause]
winter also stepped in to save one of
New York City's Treasures the costume
Institute at the Metropolitan Museum of
Art
as fundraiser in Chief she hosts the
annual Gala
it was something that rivaled even the
Oscars
Emily Rafferty is president of the
Metropolitan Museum of Art this last
year we raised in one night through her
leadership over nine million dollars
even in a time of recession
there are other formidable challenges in
front of winter Conde Nast has
admittedly been slow to adapt to the
digital age now Vogue and Winter's
future depend on it any monthly magazine
really needs to examine that there's
demand
for immediate information how do you
supply that demand
her monthly magazine faces increasing
competition from bloggers and
interactive websites that have given
designers a new platform to instantly
showcase their designs and
simultaneously sell their products
relying Less on glossy photo spreads in
Vogue this season Philip limb is all
about outerwear winter now shares the
coveted front row with New Media
I guarantee you that Anna will change
the game of digitized content we're
taking branded content with her voice to
millions of consumers that we couldn't
possibly touch with a magazine as an
exclusive medium
winter her colleagues and critics alike
believe has transcended the medium she
has become the curator of worldwide
fashion
[Applause]
[Music]
Anna does something almost every day
that's huge she always has an idea of
pushing this industry and sort of
pushing it further and further
this is a multi hundred billion dollar
Global industry and that is a byproduct
of many things but one of them is Anna's
stewardship of Vogue magazine in 20 plus
years she's got this incredible
reference point of what
good fashion is and what talent is and
what creativity is
she's not here just to say whether a
dress looks nice or not or whether a new
shoe is groovy enough
she's really there to encourage the
entire industry young Talent established
Talent these are all difficult balls to
keep in there but she feels that this is
her Duty
this is her Legacy as well
she is the woman that bought fashion
really
to Big Business
and to the world
globally
[Music]
[Applause]
he is the Fashion World reigning
superpower whatever aspect of the
business that you're in in our industry
everybody looks at Ralph Lauren as the
model A Dream Maker who netted billions
by imagining what others wished for
every time I design clothes I'm making a
movie I don't think anybody since Walt
Disney has been as successful in
persuading millions and millions of
people to buy into his fantasies
wherever you go Ralph Lawrence Brands
project an aura of rarified living
Ralph's brand stands for classic
Timeless fashion the brand represents
your souvenir of this fabulous lifestyle
that you want to be a part of but his
life was not his picture perfect my
sense was he thought that would be the
last time he walked the wrong way it
wasn't not by a long shot we used to
joke that he always had a plan to take
over the world he's taken over the world
who's no doubt about it
Ralph Lauren is the most famous one-man
brand on the planet a brand that is
synonymous with a superior lifestyle
Ralph always knew that he wouldn't win
if he didn't take risks he's always
pushing the envelope he keeps himself
awake at night he's worried that he's
going to fail he's obsessed
um he's brilliant he's irascible he's
difficult and he can also be kind and
interesting and sweet he's a huge bundle
of contradictions Lauren insists that
the images he creates communicate his
story and did not participate in the
show before he was Ralph Lauren he was
Ralph lifshitz the youngest of four
children who wore his brother's
hand-me-downs born in 1939 to Jewish
immigrant working-class parents he grew
up in the Bronx New York his father was
a house painter and amateur artist
living with someone for whom Aesthetics
mattered would of course affect a child
in that household Michael Gross is the
author of genuine authentic the real
life of Ralph Lauren he went to Yeshiva
and he wore a yamaka and he wore all the
other paraphernalia of Orthodox Jews
every single day he told me that at the
very beginning when he was living in the
Bronx he would go and escape to the
movie theater and literally fall into
the fantasies of the movies of that era
which was really you know one of the
great movie going years the late 40s and
early 50s Warren helstein is one of
Lauren's Boyhood friends we all as kids
looked at the movie screens and the
actors and how good they looked I know
Ralph particularly liked Fred Astaire
and he truly did project himself into
the scenes in which men like Gary Cooper
and Cary Grant were playing he sees the
characters that populate his dreams and
his visions and that Vision that ability
to step into a fantasy world Ralph
brought to the fashion business in one
of his only two major television
interviews ever Lauren told Charlie Rose
back in 1993 about the enduring impact
of those experiences I was very
influenced by movies
I was very influenced by
a world that had a sense of dream
that had a sense of something else and
what I was influenced in these places
was
the good guy the the the the Hopalong
Cassidy um
not the corny guy but there was the man
on the White Horse my sense was
I had an Integrity inside me about what
I believed in
I I did it honestly
and but I had a point of view I was very
strong Warren helstein says that when
they were teenagers Lauren asked
helsteen's father a tailor to make him
one of his first suits but I remember
going down to my father's place with him
and it was very difficult
if you haven't just said my father's dad
do whatever he likes
he says I can't please him I said okay
that's
that's it even though he was a
perfectionist Lauren was a guy's guy he
liked basketball best I would say it's
okay we're all good
in 2011 when Oprah Winfrey came to
interview him on his Colorado Ranch
Lauren shared his earliest Ambitions did
you always want to be a cowboy I want to
be a baseball player I want to be
basketball player I wanted to be an
actor I want to be a dancer actually I
wanted to be Batman if you don't if
that's the secret I'm telling you
everyone out there when he was in his
late teens he and his brother Jerry
opted for a name change as Ralph said to
me the problem with the name lift
says it had the word in it and he
endured endless teasing that continued
through school I'm sure into the army I
believe that Ralph suggested to me that
the name Lauren came from Lauren Bacall
who you know was a great style icon as
well as a great actress following High
School Lauren worked as a Salesman while
taking business classes at night he
never got a degree in 1964 after a short
stint in the Army 26 year old Lauren
married Ricky lobeer a receptionist he
met at a doctor's office he married the
girl who would look perfect in the
convertible with her blonde hair flowing
Ricky became his model his his backstop
Ricky was always I think in the back of
his mind
[Music]
still looking for his place in the world
Lawrence set his sights on New York's
fashion industry he became a Salesman
for Brooks Brothers and then a series of
necktie manufacturers I took him to his
first polo match in blindbrook where we
were
exposed to Fabulous things
the silver the leather the horses the
tall Slinky blondes big hats and just a
high society that we really weren't uh
knowledgeable of
but certainly
it didn't take us a moment to appreciate
it that fabulous World transformed
Lauren's Vision he called me up and said
he was going to open up his own business
and what was my opinion about the name
and he said he had it down to players
or Polo and I said Ralph
Polo is totally elitist
hardly anybody knows anything about it
but everybody plays something there's no
choice it's got to be players he said
okay thanks a lot and goodbye and then
the rest is history
it was the era of plain narrow ties when
Lauren offered up a radical design
concept colorful why ties
striking out on his own one of his first
stops Bloomingdale's Marvin Traub was
the former CEO and president of
Bloomingdale's shortly before he died he
spoke about the Brash young designer he
showed them to the Bloomingdale tie
buyer who said I like them I'll buy them
but I don't want that Ralph Lauren label
on it I want a Bloomingdale label now
here's Ralph's starting and struggling
in business about to get an order from
blooming Bells he closed the sample case
and said I will not accept the order
without my name
[Music]
several months after Ralph Lauren walked
away from an offer at Bloomingdale's the
renowned store called him back I thought
the ties were terrific and if he wanted
his name on it that was fine because I
felt the tithes would sell and they did
other well-known names in men's clothing
also wanted in including Paul Stewart
and Neiman Marcus
within a year Lauren sold a whopping
half million dollars of ties the
designer had designs on something even
bigger to expand his brand
he aimed to do so he told Charlie Rose
by envisioning clothing that he himself
would want to wear what you thought you
can buy in England what you thought Cary
Grant was wearing and Fred is there you
could not walk into a store and buy when
I came along the business was not at all
like the things that I made you could
not buy you couldn't find it
Bloomingdale's saw potential and profit
in Lauren's line we worked closely at
from the ties to men's shirts to Suits
sport coats slacks a total men's
collection and then he came and said
Marvin I'd like to do a women's business
I think the most important break for
Ralph Lauren was probably getting a
boutique of his own in Bloomingdale's it
was the moment when someone outside of
Ralph's fantasy existence agreed with
him and brought him into the world of
Commerce this was the first time that
Bloomingdale's had given a designer his
own in-store Boutique and the business
grew very rapidly Ralph has in
everything else knew exactly what he
wanted in the shop what he wanted on the
floor is what he wanted on the walls it
created really a Ralph Lauren
environment and it's all Ralph's dream
menswear designer John Varvatos was a
protege of Lawrence if you go back into
the 60s and 70s people put things on a
mannequin they never told stories Ralph
took you into a fantasy world wealth
took you to an island he took you to The
Hamptons he took you to the West
three years after his first ties went on
sale Lauren won the Oscar of the fashion
industry the 1970 Cody award for his
menswear line and in 1971 Lauren bought
the first of what would be many luxury
cars Pulitzer Prize architecture and
design critic Paul goldberger has
reported on Ralph Lauren's famous car
collection I think it was a Mercedes
convertible that he couldn't quite
afford at that point he bought anyway uh
because he
understand that very kind of
aspirational reach that he's trying to
sell to other people he reached back to
his earlier fantasy that polo match
and introduced his signature emblem the
polo player but despite strong sales the
company found itself in financial
trouble to keep it going Lauren was
forced to invest most of his personal
savings one hundred thousand dollars he
also hired a new business partner retail
executive Peter strong who pitched in
and bought 10 of the business for six
thousand dollars I think he was very
worried they were delivering everything
late their distribution pattern was all
wrong we solved those problems and we
got the right stores to buy the right
amount of things to display everything
properly two years after strom's arrival
and back on track Lauren's brand got a
boost when his men's clothes were cast
in The Great Gatsby his ability to
create clothes that looked like costumes
that looked like clothes that looked
like costumes was unequaled in American
fashion hi hi but I actually think that
the claim that he designed Annie Hall
was more important the Annie Hall look
would Inspire one of Lauren's earliest
women's Collections and the designer
himself was often the featured model in
his Brand's ad campaigns commercial
director Jeff Madoff has shot many of
Ralph Lauren's fashion shows he wears
this stuff so he's become the embodiment
of what he creates like Frank Perdue
with his chickens you know Ralph in his
clothes there was an authenticity to it
the company launched a blitz of new
collections including a wide-ranging
home collection
Lauren also licensed his name to other
products trading a measure of control
for Capital
now flush with cash in 1986 Ralph Lauren
went all in spending 30 million dollars
to open a standalone flagship store
housed in New York City's historic
Rhinelander Mansion my wife and I were
there opening day at two o'clock in the
afternoon
and I settled in the store it's packed
with people I said Ralph how are you
doing he said I think I'm doing all
right and I said Ralph you're a retailer
you can ring off the cash register now
and the manager
came back and said we have forty one
thousand dollars in and Ralph said is
that good and I said that's very good
then I went back to my office and the
phone rings about 5 30 and it's Ralph
Marvin we have a hundred and one
thousand dollars in how is that and I
said it was terrific this was Ralph
learning to be a retailer I think it
told his story to the world anybody who
came to New York it's like on the tour
guide of New York you know you
understand Ralph Lauren's message very
clearly when you go through there when
you walk by those windows you get it as
the business continued to grow Lauren
pushed his employees harder than ever
there's a vast team of designers and
creative executives
they do the designing they do just about
everything but they bring it to Ralph
and finally it's Ralph who decides and
there are actually this amazing thing
little tiny stickers that get put up on
idea boards and they say RL likes
and in that act Ralph Lauren takes
possession of those clothes of those
designs and deserves the credit Ralph
pays more attention to detail than
anybody I've ever met in my life and
when he is designing
and he's looking at the clothes he'll
look and want a lapel ever seem much
more peaked or ever so much narrower or
he likes the Plaid but he wants it to be
bigger
in 1986 the estimated worth of the
privately held company was 600 million
dollars and Lauren not his models was
the cover shot it would seem that life
couldn't get any better for Lauren when
he launched his next women's collection
but behind the scenes something very
alarming was shaking up the famed
designer we were top of the Saint Regis
Hotel
and the finale of the show
Ralph came out
and I saw his face unlike I had seen it
before
and as I was fighting back tears I
started crying because there was
something going on I didn't even know
what it was it was just visceral
no one but those closest to him knew
that Lauren had been diagnosed with a
brain tumor
it was one of those things that you just
didn't want to believe couldn't happen
to Ralph what did it mean for the future
there was all those questions at the
time
[Music]
as I was riding home in the taxi and I
heard on the news reports that Designer
Ralph Lauren was being admitted for
emergency brain surgery
wow oh yeah my God
sure I worried
not so bad for him you know
fortunately the tumor was benign
after surgery there was a long road
ahead and new priorities oh I don't
think you worried about what would
happen to the business I think he
worried about living about his life
Lauren shared his ordeal with Charlie
Rose I remember when I came home from
the hospital
and uh
I took a walk in Central Park and I was
very weak
and I saw some guys running in the park
running and sweating I said to myself
I want to do that
several weeks later Lauren returned to
work so I think he came back even more
aggressive than ever but I think he was
a little bit more relaxed
a little bit more laid back and maybe
was valuing every moment a little bit
more
he launched a fitness wear collection
and created a top-selling perfume he
spent Millions promoting these lines and
the product Universe surrounding them
James Fallon editor of women's wear
daily calls Ralph Lauren a Powerhouse in
the magazine world because he's one of
the biggest advertisers out there if I
launch my fragrance and I take an ad out
and or series of ads you're going to
then do a profile of me I mean look at
the number of magazines that did put him
on the cover when he had his 40th
anniversary and that reflects the extent
to which they appreciated his financial
support in past years appreciated and
also depended on it a 200 million dollar
annual advertising budget is an 800
pound gorilla Ralph Lauren sits wherever
he wants and if that's the cover of your
magazine Ralph's gonna be there Lauren's
dominance was also evident when Audrey
Hepburn presented him with the Council
of American fashion designers Lifetime
Achievement Award there was one of his
Muses his icons Audrey Hepburn the woman
that he watched when he was a little kid
in the movies now can sending him this
statue that for him could have been the
Oscar remember the princess I got her
with the launch of Lauren's upscale
Purple Label in 1994 the company looked
great to the untrained eye after all
sales were at an all-time high but that
only told half the story
the prabhakar is a retail business
journalist like every retailer that has
Big Dreams it just grew too quickly
there was a lot of capital expended in
order to make that brand where he wanted
to be that combined with a very
lackluster operations in terms of
distribution created really a perfect
storm for a company that was almost on
the brink of bankruptcy Lauren needed a
lifeline and found it with Goldman Sachs
the investment firm purchased 28 of Polo
Ralph Lauren for 135 million dollars
that was surprising to us because we
never realized that he had been that
close to the you know back to the wall
financially and I think that's sort of
what led to the Goldman Sachs investment
they're very good about identifying
where the growth is and what's going to
be a company that's going to have
long-term growth and that's exactly what
they saw in Ralph Lauren and the
infusion of cash meant exponential
growth with Polo Ralph Lauren opening
new doors and overhauling older ones by
1997 Ralph Lauren was the top selling
designer in the world consumers spent
almost five billion dollars a year on
his products Goldman Sachs saw greater
potential and pressed Lauren to go
public he wasn't so sure he always had
concerns that once it was a public
company he would have less freedom of
action that was no longer his own brand
because he had shareholders and a board
to deal with
[Music]
despite his initial reservations Ralph
Lauren decided to take his company
public in June 1997. Liz Dunn a retail
Analyst at Macquarie Capital has been
tracking Lauren's company for years part
of the challenge with going public is
that investors want to see growth
quarter to quarter year to year in a
very consistent linear fashion and so I
think in the early days of the company's
history as a public company they sort of
struggled with that when he first went
public we would cover his annual
meetings and he would stand in front of
a shareholders going Wall Street doesn't
understand me our shares aren't are just
sitting there they don't really move I
wish they would get what we do Lauren
was now working to satisfy his
shareholders the company began to sell
in more stores but sales growth slowed
and profit margins declined and 16
months after its opening day high of 33
dollars a share it fell below 17.
I know that it tormented him we talked
about it
um he talked about it he was frustrated
that Wall Street couldn't see what was
abundantly clear to him and always had
been since 1967 that he was it that he
was the guy it drove him crazy
um and he was into that environment that
came a man named Roger Farrah who was
one of the great retail Executives in
America Roger Farrah came over and
really restructured the unsexy parts of
the business supply chain operations one
thing he also did too was that he bought
back those licenses he brought those
Brands back in house and made sure that
all those Brands were underneath the
Ralph Lauren umbrella they're going
through a tremendous growth period
and I had suggested that we put together
something that really codify the polo
brand message and we called it Ralph
Lauren philosophy it's a brand video
that Lauren commissioned the way I do
collections what inspires me is the
story of a theme that gets to me that
says I know how to build this I don't
build a collection from a sleeve or from
a specific fabric I build it out of a
dream control to him is very important
and this was a way to present a unified
message where he didn't have to be there
but it was like he was there
Lauren continued to expand with an eye
on International sales he opened
Flagship stores in Milan Tokyo and even
Moscow America is represented in France
by McDonald's and Ralph Lauren I mean
you know which one makes our culture
look better in Paris I think the Ralph
Lauren store it's really become a kind
of symbolic American Embassy but in the
summer of 2012 the All-American designer
was attacked when news reports revealed
that the Team USA uniforms Lauren
designed were not made in the USA made
in China this is China China I think
they should take all the uniforms put
them in a big pile and burn them the
company said the uniforms for the 2014
Winter Games would be produced in the
United States
throughout his career Ralph Lauren has
carefully cultivated his own image he
has homes on Fifth Avenue in Jamaica
Long Island and Bedford New York as well
as a 17 000 acre ranch in Colorado where
he spends time with his wife and three
grown children he also spends time and
lots of money on his pet passion cars
fun and toys and they all offer you a
different experience to me their works
of art this 2010 promotional video
announces a Paris exhibit of some of
Lauren's 60 plus vintage cars he once
told me his car collection is something
he does
first because he just loves cars and
responds to them and he doesn't collect
art
unlike most people in his income bracket
he said you know you can't drive a
painting and he loves the idea of being
able to take any of his cars and drive
it around on a Sunday afternoon Paul
goldberger says that Lauren has changed
some of the car's original colors he
sort of looks at something and says
this is wonderful and exciting and
beautiful but it actually could be even
better and I want to make it even more
perfect for 40 years Ralph Lawrence
pursuit of perfection has kept him
firmly in charge as CEO and chairman of
the board of the company that wears his
name I think that that you know small
symbol of the polo pony is is enduring
and it's something that customers over a
long period of time have chosen this is
probably the best long-term story in my
coverage because there are these variety
of growth opportunities that are really
driving a doubling or more of sales over
the next several years the former AI
salesman at age 72 is one of the world's
wealthiest people worth seven and a half
billion dollars
I think that the last piece of Ralph
lifshitz that remains in Ralph Lauren is
a kernel of insecurity and it is the
fuel that runs the engine that runs the
person who personifies the brand Ralph
doesn't sit on his Laurels for one
minute not for one minute I mean you can
enjoy the moment but you have to
understand that you have to keep things
going and you can't be a one-trick pony
speaking of police
it's not one of the most important but
it's never on sale
and how much is that
[Music]
how about this one
this one should be 26.50 these are ready
and are around 3 500.
4 000 at most it's calfskin with embryo
Dairy otherwise there's python skin
ranging from 3000 to 5000.
how about this crocodile skin bag it's
the ultimate precious bag and that's 29.
29 000 Euro
[Music]
luxury designers famous worldwide aren't
feeling the economic squeeze and in the
fashion capsule people crowd in even on
a normal weekday afternoon our journey
starts in the temple of Milan's designer
labels the Fashion District the queen of
via Montana is Gucci the identity of
this brand is based on a craftsmanship
of the Florentine Masters and the
leather goods are its Prestige sector
the same goes for potato recalling the
plating of the leather goods
manufacturers
Italian labels owned by the French and
together with YSL and other caring group
labels are invoicing in Switzerland
and fine
[Music]
how much are these
the same price 14.90
1580.
today we did all kinds of brands do we
put in foreign
[Music]
as well
where have you manufactured recently
high boots they gave me 40.
[Music]
are they from the latest winter
collection
Gucci even gave me the sewing machine
are you using it yes we made a lot of
boots with that Gucci is always asking
for boots or sandals
how many do they give you every day
about 100 pairs but they're complicated
just Gucci every day 100 pairs
the men we talked to is a subcontractor
and inside this Workshop luxury shoes
are made the designer design the model
makers do prototypes but the big fashion
house turn to high-level firms which
assign the job to subcontractors the
Craftsman for the actual production
our first stop to find out who is suing
the luxury bags and shoes is rivieria
Del brenta from Venice the shoe industry
Center of Excellence Italy's flagship
the Shoemaker store advised us to come
here they said you make shoe uppers
yes
Celeron
we made 2 000 pairs of this model
the upper is the visible part of the
shoe suing it is the most important
manufacturing step to shoe making the
Chinese specialize in this production
[Music]
it's similar what model is that
Ferragamo
how much do they pay you for this
talk about prices he makes us move away
from the workbenches because the amount
he gets from the supplier is not the
same of what he pays to the worker who
is suing the shoes
we get 23 for this
I told the worker let's say that I give
four to them and six to me we usually
set the prices this way with Ferragamo
the prices goes higher
how many can they make
every day 25 pairs you pay them by the
shoe they keep working day and night so
they can make more
if you think that we're not legitimate
almost all the Chinese work this way
it's useless to tell us that we are not
legitimate
payments by pair of shoes and piecework
is illegal if the shoe factory gives the
Chinese 23 Euros the worker is paid 4
Euros to make a pair of boots and it's a
model by Ferragamo of the current
collection
they're from the latest runway show
you're counting a lot on these boots
this year how much are they
is it the difficulty of this production
deciding the price yes that's because
our shoes are still almost entirely
handmade These Are Made in Florence our
headquarters are in Florence we make
them here
this also justifies the price
foreign
who gives you the Saint Laurent orders
Dustin Laura know
the salon supervisor came to the
workshop to check
I'll show you one model
this model with the circles and the
ankle strap this model has been around
for two years
would you like to try them on
how much are they
[Music]
we are talking about the tribute sandal
an iconic model by YSL worn on a red
carpet by Adriana Lima Kaylee minnow
Jennifer Lopez Julia Roberts Beyonce
they pay you 9 Euros a pair How many
pairs
for ten thousand nine euros just for the
upper and another four Euros for the
coding
how much would a legitimate Italian
Craftsman cost a lot probably given that
since 2
150 local upper manufacturers closed
down and 300 new Chinese Workshop opened
at that time we met on the condition of
anonymity a subcontractor manufacturer
who had always sewn designer shoes the
Gucci boot I showed you is sold between
1300 to 1800 Euros for that Gucci boot
they gave me 60 Euros the brand pays 180
to the shoe manufacturers that gives me
the job that's ten percent that's why
they don't want people to know that the
actual cost of the luxury shoes
materials and manufacturers is 10 to 15
at the most of the final price all
inclusive
heels assembly General expenses box
everything of that 10 paid by the brand
the manufacturers represent the cost
between 40 and 60 percent it also
depends on the type of manufacturer and
the type of shoe and Court shoes will
take 22 minutes to make for a Gucci
court shoe they will give me 9 euros
Donald
the cost of a Craftsman is calculated
per minute but the processing time may
vary between 20 minutes and 4 hours
depending on the shoe the labor costs
the cost of those who make the shoes
that will get lower
they will strangle you on labor costs
because the Chinese will cut them by
half how can they ask for half of the
production costs because instead of
eight hours they'll double their working
hour or they get paid under the table
they are boycotting us on hourly rates
if I'm legitimate I cannot ask for less
than 18 to 20 euros per hour they keep
asking to lower our prices and we the
subcontractors feel trapped
indeed for the YSL sandal the legitimate
manufacturer cost would be around 30
Euros the Chinese told us he gets 9
Euros plus 4 Euros for the coding and
that's less than half we brought a shoe
upper whose manufacturing cost was
estimated at 30 Euros in one day this
price has considerably lowered
only for the shoe upper I should decide
it 15 is fine
yes 15.
how much for this
eight
good you can do it all right
if I do it as for the luxury brand 8
euros foreign
on the international level there isn't a
law forcing fashion house to control
their production chain at the moment
only Gucci has pledged its social
responsibility with an ethical
certification sa 8000. this means
ensuring the customer and improving the
company's reputation that their products
were made respecting the rights of the
workers across the entire chain of
suppliers and subcontractors in recent
years some of the caring group brands
have been more careful regarding the
production someone from the upper
management wants to check what happens
then the show Factory gives us some of
the shoes in small quantities so they
can come to us for their inspection and
show they are working with good
Craftsmen we are only a front but then
the big quantities go to the Chinese
foreign
who's to blame if the prices are too low
the brand names at the head of the chain
or those who subcontract the shoe
factory is signing a contract with the
main office it's hard to determine the
legal responsibilities without the
transparency of the production chain
this way as long as sweated labor is
concerned the company can just shrug and
say I knew nothing about it
there is a connivance of the brands in
this because they are the ones imposing
the prizes the factories must work for
it is no longer the factories making a
quote and proposing it but it's the main
office that will impose a production
rate then the factory will have to
recoup within the production chain it's
their problem
foreign
we're talking about a product that has
such a high markup that all the workers
could make a good living we were asking
for more transparency in the production
chain then again it takes two to reach
an agreement
they never approved it
our proposals were never accepted
[Music]
they said the factory had closed down
but it kept working the Chinese are
still there and they never take a
vacation
the dismissal was motivated by
determination of the company I was also
told Saturday you'll work for eight
hours for free I refused right away to
threaten me they fired the worker
we want to work it's our right to work
legally
we are in the center of Florence a group
of 13 snake workers is demonstrating in
front of the building of region Toscana
their contract was not renewed after
they asked to legalize their working
positions the company in question is
posetta a chinese-run firm specialize in
metal work but not of any metal work we
are talking about the designer buckles
of luxury Brands The Firm gets worked
directly from the first level right in
front of them
our firm is here with that Red Gate in
the back there is polzetta Workshop
and the offices right here in front of
us
that's right what happens after all the
original buckles arrive
they take them there we work on them and
they go back where they came from
how many items a day are you working on
one day I did 3 350 items they were
buckled for bags
Abdul's task is it means staying for
hours bent over a tub polishing the
buckles for designer bags and shoes and
it's a very hard job
we did a lot of different brands
Prada Gucci Giorgio Armani Hermes also
Valley
[Music]
Bulgari
yeah I worked 11 hours Monday through
Friday on Saturday I give them six hours
nobody pays me for them
the word gift was used by them
that's what they're telling you gift me
or I'll send you away from the Chinese
law rules
[Music]
but not only a gifting system of
overtime was in place part of the
paycheck about 200 Euros a month was
given back under the table
they take everything away from you
but a regular contract stays in place
you have to give them back the cash okay
for instance when you go to the bank it
looks as though they truly paid you
everything then you have to go get the
money and give it back to them
entirely alone
they ask you what is your bank they even
drive you there you get to the ATM and
get the money if you do it they renew
your contract and if you don't they send
you away
this is called extortion but this way
your paycheck is clean
I'd like to talk to the owner of
positive if I may
he doesn't want to do the interview
could I talk to Mr binzy
there is no one by the name
isn't he the owner of one of these three
firms I don't know goodbye
we are here on the premise of the same
firm that was closed down and formerly
had another name
only the minority of the singly's
workers was brave enough to turn to the
labor unions no complaint ever came from
a hundred or so Chinese workers
the Chinese know about the firm and
their home they don't care about
anything else
and Louis they hire Chinese people
husbands and wives they took work 13
hours a day
how do they Chinese live do they sleep
there in the parking lot do they sleep
in the car that's where they live
producing in Florence has an added value
the Tuscan territory has a great
manufacturing tradition regarding both
leather and metal work so much so that
Gucci That is forte in an advertising
campaign
instead of bringing the work to China
they brought the Chinese here they
reversed the course
it's no coincidence if the issue after
taking to the streets involving the
government and especially the newspapers
subsided with the reinstatement of the
dismissed workers nevertheless these are
the luxury workers and these are their
homes
but the fact that the production workers
come out of the woodwork to assert their
rights is an exception especially where
jobs are scarce Naples is our last stop
it's one of the most important Italian
leather districts the Napoleon
craftsmanship tradition is famous
worldwide
foreign
for which brands did you experience the
worst conditions
Gucci Gucci was too much Fendi
too much referred to the conditions
they make you sign a three-hour contract
they pay you very little when they want
to and how they want to the contract for
three hours
three hours a day and how long did you
work eight hours or even longer
what about the wage
real low 30 Euros a day the final
paycheck
500 600 470.
you only did Gucci for Gucci for five
years in this field I've been working
for 25 years
how old were you when you started 12 13.
in 25 years working as a diet at
subcontractor factories the worker
talking to us dyed the leather of bags
and purses for major fashion houses
his testimony courageous for accepting
to tell us is only an example of a
situation labor unions describe as
desperate but when a factory has dozens
of three-hour contracts
how can nobody suspect that it might be
sweated labor I just cannot believe that
the main office has no idea of such a
situation
when the size of the phenomenon of
sweated labor of underpayment lack of
Rights is so huge that it covers the
vast majority of luxury workers how can
they not know
it's impossible not to know they could
tell me it's none of my business I gave
them work it's the factories who are
responsible I'm washing my hands of it
we are in the outer Northern outskirts
of Naples Beyond scampia and second
dicliano around casandrino Arizona
all neighboring municipalities the
leather factories are gathered most of
them aren't direct suppliers but
subcontractors where you may find the
most difficult situations this one in
Via Paolo barcelino is the most visible
build up area the rest of the factories
are hard to detect most of the factories
around here are like this yellow one
here it is simply the ground floor of
the houses where someone else live just
go inside the courtyard and you will see
on the ground floor instead of a garage
there's a small leather goods shoes or
even clothing Factory
foreign
we find factories who only work
illegally they are not registered they
almost don't exist but in this case as
well we're talking about thousands of
workers in this area it's hard to find
factories where workers earn at least a
minimum wage it's a rarity when you do
find one
when a Gucci inspectors were expected
they said they will be here tomorrow
clean up the factory and the Gucci
inspectors would come yes but two days
before we were notified that the
inspectors would come we obviously had
to wear our coats ear protectors goggles
the factory was so clean as we could
only dream for the rest of the time
as soon as they left everything turned
back as it was
did they check the contracts
I think so
did they ever ask you anything they
weren't going to ask the workers
directly how much do you make a day how
many hours are you working
foreign
by one story in particular where they
make counterfeit items a business
notoriously in the hands of the
organized crime sometimes they also
receive the real stuff there was a
seized Workshop we worked inside I
didn't know the name of my employer who
used to call us with a disposable cell
phone
foreign
excuse me what is your name what's it to
you he used to pay us in his car he'd
take the money from an envelope or a box
on the back seat
we used to make counterfeit items
but you did realize you were also making
the real stuff
sometimes we did
how could you tell
a little tap inside was missing from the
counterfeit
nothing without intestinal the
manufacturing was identical
identical same material same stitching
same color same manufacturing
didn't they tell you make them better no
they were just the same
how long did you work four or five
months and they still owe 100 euros the
counterfeit was better
[Laughter]
download
this is the absurdity of it all we're
talking about products of incredible
value but those who make them are
treated under third world conditions
when I am accusing a company for the
transparency of its supply chain and the
wages because I'm suspecting they are
low but I don't know for sure I am
accusing it because they are doing all
they can do to save money and they are
jeopardizing the factories they hired
because if the factory owners hardly
scrape by there's nothing they can do
you are jeopardizing the worker as well
they're putting money before anything
else even before people's dignity if
that's not a problem